ja und dann habe ich sogar noch zulegen
gesagt leute ich bin hier einer aus der
nummer raus ist es asozial 15
das problem ist hätte er lässt sich aber
nicht mehr gehen außer du zahlst 13.000
euro ausbaukosten vertrag ist
unterschrieben
herzlich und so neue leute heute mal in
einem etwas anderen setting leute denn
wir haben es möglich gemacht dass
tatsächlich geschafft heute kommt ein
neues interview mit einem hilf mir dass
er leute und ich rede gar nicht lange
drumherum
herzlich willkommen marcel leute ganz
kurz kurze einen für euch falls ihr das
gesicht noch nicht zuordnen können
man kann schon sagen marcel ist so einer
der es auf youtube hilfe mehr so hat in
der zweiten folge mit 6,8 millionen
aufrufen die hilfe mein freund mich und
auch in teil 2 natürlich mitgespielt mit
3,6 millionen aufrufen also allein in
den beiden volk über 10 millionen
aufrufe auf youtube also schon und jetzt
hier bei uns sollte das ganze so laufen
dass dieses interview in zwei teile
aufteilen werden das jetzt erste teil
ist ein teig und dann wird man die tage
und ich würde sagen ja sogar direkt
loslegen muss erste frage von bonus
hahaha wie kommt man dazu so was zu
machen
vertreibung möglich
es gibt die theorie dass der serie sich
genau auf jung da diese auch nicht
zugetroffen ich war jung ich habe meine
zweifel
nee ich tatsächlich was so ich hab noch
nie für rtl oder so mitgespielt oder so
damit gemacht ich habe damals sehr viel
für prosieben gedrehte kabel eins und
sat 1 die kraft und den seriöseren
serien sag jetzt mal über zum beispiel
schicksal und plötzlich ist alles anders
es ist so gute zeiten obwohl es ziemlich
100 euro gekauft hab genau und meine
damalige regisseur in die ko die hat
mich damals angerufen die es dann zu rtl
gewechselt und hat mich angerufen hat
sie keine zeit ich habe eine menge coole
war das für dich aber ich habe davon
machen wie ich kenne sie sehr sehr lange
kann man geht ja nicht ich hasse dich
dafür ja das war halt das problem so das
war dieser rtl 5 der sie dann auch so
beharrte dann hat sie nicht alles
verraten wer hat gesagt ja da geht es
nur darum dass es hilft mir ich kann das
format davor gar nicht und du musst da
nur irgendwie so ein bisschen was machen
und eine kussszene aber das wird alles
floriert und ich so ja auch fehler zu
machen
problem war an der ganzen sache ich habe
keinen druck bekommen ich habe nur nur
den vertrag bekommen und daher de caro
ja sehr viele jahre kennen und ihr
vertrauen ich gesagt du machen wir
lieben eingescannt gleich zurück und am
selben tag ist auch zum drehen und öl
also richtig verein also demnächst so
richtig in die ecke getrieben und in die
enge gezwängt und da dachte ich mir gut
so vertrag war unterschrieben ich konnte
davon nicht mehr zurücktreten und dann
muss jetzt und dann dachte ich mir
sicher bin ich hier gelandet und dann
habe ich mir keinen drehbuch ihrem typ
nennt wird das ist das lose gruppe genau
das ist die ist es vom ausspreche was
heißt louis und ashley sind heute nacht
und dann kannst du dir alles wort
gerecht ja und dann habe ich sogar noch
zulegen gesagt leute ich bin hier fein
ausgenommen heraus es ist asozial 15
das problem ist hätte er lässt sich aber
nicht mehr gehen außer du zahlst 13.000
euro ausfallkosten vertrag ist
unterschrieben und dann legen kann ich
und das war zu kurz das ist geil das ist
ganz das wusste ich auch und doch ich
hab mal ein titel gemacht wie meistens
werde schlecht gesehen haben heute falls
nicht ist eine strahlung von links
also ich würde hättest du dachtest dann
sichtlich 10
also ist schon ein bisschen drucks oder
bei jedem fall auf jeden fall und die
wird die ganze story definitiv nicht so
verkauft wie sie dann im endergebnis und
dann bist du vor ort als vertrag schon
unterschrieben und bin auch da geht kann
ich zurück bin ich dazu gekommen
ok allem eine frage von einem kind
vielleicht auch mal ganz gut von der
geburt bis zum 25 25 aus cannabis ein
jahr bis zu 4 94 19 90 95 auch von einem
kommers war es schwer das zu spielen ja
mehr als wer also ich bin wandels blick
auf jeden fall aber das war echt
unterste schublade
da ich ja also ich bin ja bei
dreharbeiten immer mit leidenschaft und
feuer weiter aber das war echt zu ich
dachte mir also augen zu und durch
am besten wir ein team erst du manchmal
auf der straße kann tatsächlich ja also
es wurde ja viele jahre später
ausgestrahlt werden es ist wirklich ich
konnte mich am anfang wo diese
eigentlich konnte mich echt nicht mehr
retten im supermarkt überall im club wo
dich angesprochen und was die kaste will
einigung einfach war war folgende er kam
so ein junge zu mir ich möchte dass ihr
sicher ich kenne ich kenne nicht zurecht
ich habe nirgendwo anders sie habe ich
noch mit ashley zusammen bei mann hatte
gehört dieser
rahmig so ashley oder soja diese dick
ist und hilf mir also er hat echt
geglaubt dass wir das ist alles will war
aber ich dachte so nein man ja das war
wirklich richtig grundschule ich wohl
ist christ erkannt und darauf wie man
sie oft ab und zu wenn ich erstmal in
münchen das sind diese leute ist das ist
doch mal eine arztpraxis ich war
letztens ganz neue art praxis haben ja
jetzt eine blutprobe gemacht und hier
war dieser empfang gleich ums eck war
das wahlfach zimmer und sagte doch das
ist ja das ist das ist euer recht diesen
von youtube diesen hinter sind aber mit
geräuschteppich nicht der rede wert ich
habe das alles finde ich gekauft und da
dachte ich mir altern ist schon echt
krass geleistet zwei neuen bereichen wie
schaffst du es beim drehen nicht zu
lachen
du musst ganz oft lachen aus
verzweiflung ab
es wird ja immer wieder neu gedreht habe
weil der regisseur nach der kameramann
nach der alles lachen
jeder lacht mich aus in dem moment aber
ich muss man sich auch lachen und das
wird dann halt sehr lange und sehr viel
und sehr oft geprägt aber die komplette
cool also die komplette gelacht und
einem habe ich auch unsere abgebrochen
weil sie hat nichts gegen dich falls sie
das ist ein ganz liebes mädchen gewesen
aber jetzt einfach so extrem nach
schweiß gestimmt und ich habe auch
gesagt als wir brauchen jetzt ja ich
meine die flasche weil es ging einfach
nicht mehr
ihr wisst schon körper
die arbeitsbedingung es nicht und ja
eigentümers derartige für jeden was hast
du von deiner rolle gedacht hast du erst
mal bekommen hast und dann fragt man ja
anfang dachte ich mir ja ganz normale
ganz normale rolle
ich musste irgendwie küsten ich musste
halt irgendwie einen spielen macht mir
nix nix geköpfter rein in die rolle
christian ginsig und sogleich kann man
sagen dass diese vielfalt ihr das nicht
klick dazu muss man sagen dieser folge
geht es darum dass er seine freundin
freundin messe und zwar wirklich
perversen lebensmittel kombinationen
dann kannst du dich also ich fand das
eklig sie zu messen nicht alltäglich sie
zu küssen ich glaube sie kommt auch
nicht als auch nicht geil irgendwie so
diese diese eine szene da wo sie doch
gesagt hat na ja das ist meine lieblings
musste die a 10 15 mal essen die
tütenweise von dem reis gekauft und egal
ob du gerne ist oder nicht aber
irgendwann reicht's ich finde es schon
klick nötig ich habe hallo ich bin
glücklich geschädigt leute ich hab
original wenn die sätze sagt habe ich
den ton
was meinen sie tabea cheadle würdest du
nochmal jetzt kommt ich habe tatsächlich
in einer weiteren folge mitgespielt
[Musik]
sonst kriegt kann aufschlagen jeder
mensch ist häufig und ich habe muss ich
ehrlich sagen manche mit diesem rennen
ich habe tatsächlich mitgespielt aber
die ich habe davor hat das drehbuch zu
schicken lassen
+ ich habe die nase hoch gepokert und
das habe ich dann gemacht und die fand
ich gar nicht so schlimm also die ist
mir egal was die anderen sagen aber die
verkehrlich ganzes leben sind ja auch
nicht alles extrem wendig wie sie von
der malley
wenn wir also jetzt habe ich den
männlichen any heißt kurzum ich leg die
tochter flach plus die mutter also das
ist doch wirklich nicht so geradeheraus
gesagt 733 fragt waren die anderen
darsteller auch so aussieht wie sie es
in den folgen schauspielern also in
melilla also sieht wie sie total setzt
ich kann ja nur sieben uhr zahlen gleich
ein ganz liebes mädchen die macht auch
mal privat wirklich nun zeichnen dieses
mit ich glaube die hat sich einfach da
bisher ausbeuten lassen mal auch wieder
erfolg viele jeder und es ist halt
wirklich so leute die öfter man darüber
nachdenkt mit diesem serientitel sind
die darsteller gemacht weil es ist alles
gehörte nämlich das ist einfach als als
richtiger anni verkauf krass alter nach
material chile hat ein privates umfeld
dazu gehört dem ich alle meine mutter
hat gehört
wollen wir gar nicht stolz auf mich und
hat so legen erzählt er ist da wieder
dreist war wieder da und von dieser
vorgabe des erzählt bekommen die
kollegen hätten so nach da diese dinge
so wird sich so gestimmt haben wir aber
schon gefallen mein gott da das kind das
schon die liebevoll gefallen genauso wie
schon die messe hat gemeistert wird
gemessen claudia i 12 03 wie liefen die
dreharbeiten ab natürlich ganz kurz
sowie wie ist es so schreibt es ist
nicht anders erzählen und geschlechter
hat nein es ist echt unterste schublade
also kurz zum vergleich also bei meinen
arbeiten es gibt immer ein eigenes
catering für eine eigene maske dutzend
mal eigenes kostüm gehört immer jemand
der für dich zuständig ist dort aber so
alt wie bei den klamotten in die hand
gedrückt da trägt man hoch im vierten
stock
es war einfach echt unter system also
das ist nicht professionell ist richtig
schlecht auch und es gab auch nichts zum
essen also dort müsst ihr euch
vorstellen
es wird einfach irgendwie pizza oder so
gestellt und das ist so dessen acht neun
stunden drehtag und sohn das auch nur
für acht unglaublich bestellen das
musste auch sein
und wenn alle produktionen haslauer
dessen catering hat sie aussuchen so
aber dass dort eines echt sympathisch
man kann sich unterhalten okay wir
machen nicht gerade das was heute mit
dem ersten teil des interviews der
zweite teil kommt die tage leute
deswegen seid gespannt
checkt marcel okay heute mache nicht das
was heute mit dem ersten teil des
interviews der zweite teil kommt die
tage deswegen seid gespannt
checkt marcel ab was ihr macht auch
youtube videos sind verlinkt und ja ihr
kriegt hier gar nicht vorstellen könnte
man kann ich meine stärken was man tut